it's quieter than usual on Barley's
beaches tens of thousands of Chinese
tourists who would have spent their
winter holidays on the island have had
to postpone their plans because of the
corona virus outbreak for visitors from
China who landed here before the
outbreak escalated there are two choices
return home or extend their stay at
least 300 out of the 5,000 who are here
have applied for visa extensions but Yan
Dongsheng and her husband are ready to
go home the couple say they're confident
Chinese authorities and governments
around the world are handling the
situation we need to go back to our jobs
and our children need to go to school so
in our holiday ants we will immediately
return home every year around a million
Chinese tourists visit Bali and there
were direct flights from Wuhan where the
outbreak began until they were stopped a
few weeks ago as many asked how
Indonesia has seemingly avoided this
outbreak for now there's concern the
virus is present here but undetected
somewhere in this vast archipelago a
recent study by Harvard researchers
looked at data around the outbreak and
its link with air travel volume it
calculated the risk of an outbreak in
countries with direct flights to Wuhan
when the outbreak began and found the
disease could already be in Indonesia
some say Indonesia is vulnerable did not
mean a dirty but what you need to look
there are many ports of entry into the
country so many airports and ways for
people to get in and some rural areas
don't have the right equipment to detect
to the virus
but authorities here are defending
measures taken by Indonesia we've been
mapping the spread of what would happen
if there was an outbreak we have 100
hospitals ready now and more are getting
ready the facilities and personnel are
prepared the World Health Organization
also says the country is taking the
right steps to detect the virus and
prepare for cases we are fully confident
the Indonesians National Lab has the
test and they are competent to detect
any transmission it's been confirmed one
Chinese national who traveled to Bali
has contracted the virus but it's not
clear whether that happened in Bali or
elsewhere authorities are looking into
the case and on this island
many are anxiously waiting to know
Jessica Washington al Jazeera Bali